foreign
[Applause]
Americans killed by a dangerous cartel
near the border have finally been
returned to the U.S to others who
survived the kidnapping or already
repatriated to the U.S now meanwhile the
Scorpions faction of the gulf cartel
apparently issued an apology for the
murders and said those responsible have
been detained but new reports are
suggesting that the American victims may
have been involved in drug trades with
the cartel uh Lawrence Jones I saw the
Reuters report that on that very issue I
believe there's other newspaper I think
the Daily Mail am I wrong on that
yeah sorry sir you're exactly right it's
not just reports that coming from the
media with the Daily Mail as as well as
rewarders but some of my sources in law
enforcement gave me the indication that
there was already prior instances with
these victims now uh within the drug
community and they're investigating this
link between them in the cartel it was a
lot of things that just did not add up
Sean we're here at the airport right now
uh in Myrtle Beach uh and Miss McGee
just made her way back to South Carolina
we were able to speak to her just a
while ago we're the only this is
exclusively to you uh Sean she did not
answer our questions and some of the
questions I had for her was how is she
doing
um why was she in Mexico can she tell us
a little bit of what happened between
her and the cartel and my final question
to her Sean and she covered her face as
the FBI this victim Advocates willed her
uh to be reunited with her family only I
asked her was it true the reports that
there was some connection a drug deal
gone bad is what some are saying in the
law enforcement Community she just
covered her head and they wheeled her
out Sean but it's definitely something
look we've been reported on this for a
while that the Mexican cartels are
taking advantage of different trades in
America they're preying on anyone that
will get their product out to American
citizens we know the fentanyl is killing
American citizens and so because we have
not closed the Border they're taking
full of Advantage if you want to sell
dope for them or any other type of drugs
they're willing to sign you up yeah LJ
Lawrence Jones uh we'll be watching this
weekend I'm sure you will be covering it
on LJ all across America Lawrence we
always appreciate you being with us
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else